hello everyone it is a beautiful winter
day outside so I am looking at the
window thinking hmm Broly should go for
a walk it was so nice out there but I
thought I would do a quick little vlog
for you guys and you know I'm so
overwhelmed with all the amazing
feedback I've gotten on the intuitive
eating series I think it's really
helping a lot of you and I'm so
amazingly grateful for that but one of
the questions I've gone a lot on the
channel particularly on these intuitive
eating videos is whether or not you can
eat intuitively and still want to lose
weight in similar news in my own kind of
professional community I've seen a lot
of division between the Hayes dietitians
and a lot of the kind of traditional
weight loss dieticians and after
addressing some of this in my video on
the Hayes vs. weight loss Rd
philosophies here but you can check that
out
I really really started to see it and
you know I've really started think a lot
more about our roles as dietitians and
also about how our personal beliefs and
biases can play a role in our
relationship with the clients who really
entrust us to care for them now before I
get into today's rant I want of course
give my general disclaimer that the
information that I'm going to be giving
in this rant video is for entertainment
purposes only and then you should always
seek the help of a retro dietician and
doctor for your specific case
okay let's talk hey guys editing a be
here this was such an emotional video
for me to have to make and so just
looking back as I was looking at the
edits and things I just felt like I
wanted to clarify a few things that I
kind of glazed over or missed in the
heat of the moment so please do excuse
the jump cuts of meat popping in to make
some these clarifying statements so I
would say that the conversation around
food and nutrition has really never been
as divided as it is right now so on the
one hand we have like two of the most
popular ways of eating keto and
plant-based which could not be more
different
and then we have you know the popularity
and the rising popularity of health
every size and the body positivity
movement and intuitive eating you know
all of which we're seeing an even
greater divide so this has become even
more blatantly apparent to me as a
professional when I'm seeing different
dieticians on some of the professional
Facebook groups I'm in kind of argue
about different modes of treatment when
they philosophically disagree about
something or actually more unified and
United than the whole Hayes versus
weight-loss dieticians argument would
have people believe what I think that
all dietitians can agree on is that a
all body's deserve respect regardless of
size or shape we all want to denounce
die culture the fads the sensationalize
whoo the dangerous eating practices that
we often hear about on the line or you
know in the in the gym change room and
see you're not wrong for having health
or physique goals even if they don't
align with our own where I think we
potentially may see a bit of a divide is
when we start to think about goals and
when the clients goals specifically is
to lose weight I used to really fully
understand that perspective but since I
did that video you know when I came to
terms with living in the gray area
between the haze and the weight loss
dietitian paradigms I can't say that I
fully agree anymore so let's think about
some of those options and play out some
of those scenarios if a client came to
me and said hey I really want to lose
weight what is the ethical thing to do
is it to say no sorry I cannot help you
and then let them seek out a health care
professional or practitioner who
specializes in weight loss I get that
sometimes a client and a practitioner
you know may not be a good fit they may
not match well or if a particular case
feels a little bit out of scope for that
particular dietitian and they they may
want to refer out totally get that my
concern would be about just you know
sending somebody away because they are
seeking weight loss I would just be
worried that they would then seek the
advice of
an unregulated professional whose
recommendations are potentially so
dangerous that it could further
perpetuate body distrust body image
issues lead to disordered eating etc so
in contrast you know I I don't know I
might be more apt to try to say okay got
it I understand your goals why don't we
try to make some small meaningful
measurable changes that feel good to us
all the while downplaying weight loss as
the the kind of marker of success that
we're after and celebrating other kind
of you know health or behavioral
improvements that were working on and at
the same time maintaining a body
positive attitude as a practitioner in
our conversations I don't know I guess
I'm starting to see this kind of the
same as as how I see not letting our
other personal experiences or you know
personal opinions or biases interfere
with our professionalism so it's like
you know can only a vegan registered
dietitian counsel somebody on eating a
vegan diet or can only a mom registered
dietitian council parent on helping her
child eat better I would argue no I
think personal experience can be both a
really good thing but also a potential
bias so I think acknowledging that bias
and also at the same time remaining
remaining evidence-based and client
centered is really the key to being a
great practitioner interestingly I think
that both days dietitians and
weight-loss dietitians
are being both evidence-based and client
focused in their own way there is no
right or wrong here it's just different
ways of practicing there is evidence
that a haze or an on diet approach can
help promote sustainable long term
health there is also a lot of people who
could potentially benefit from weight
loss not necessarily just the weight
loss alone but yeah for certain ailments
it definitely does play a solid role and
while I've definitely heard a lot of
haze dietitians insist that you know by
refusing to counsel on weight loss
they're maintaining their ethical
promise to do no harm I don't think
black or white this is definitely a
murky space for all parading in but my
personal stance is that we need to meet
people where they are and help them
achieve their goals in a way that best
serves their emotional and physical
health I also want to clarify that you
know for the purposes of the short rant
video I'm kind of having to generalize
large groups of people into discrete
categories but the reality is you know
dieticians who practice from a weight
neutral perspective and dietitians who
counsel on weight loss are not
necessarily too discreet you know
individually mutually exclusive groups
I'm not the only dietician out there who
can respect both modes of practice but
ultimately this is something that is
really troubling for me and that's why
I'm talking about it again here and and
it's something that I've personal a lot
of my colleagues that is really
troubling for them because it's not easy
to operate in the gray but ultimately I
really do see this as an individualized
risk benefit analysis so for some people
I II like people with you know a history
of disordered eating or an active eating
disorder it would be unethical of course
to help them lose weight as the benefit
of the client being more comfortable in
a smaller body would absolutely not be a
weighed by the health risks of helping
them do that but for others it's very
possible that some modest weight loss
could potentially improve health while
not triggering disorderly thoughts so
it's very much an individual thing and
the analysis could look very different
for different people and the
recommendations could also look very
different for different people it's not
easy
operating in the gray and I think you
know it's like every question doesn't
have a straightforward a plus B equals C
answer but I think being a really good
practitioner is doing that work every
single time you know it's asking lots of
questions about every single case and
making sure to do that benefit risk
analysis for all of
them so what does that mean for those of
you who say you know oh the idea that
diets don't work is both because maybe
you or somebody you know went on a diet
and lost weight you know I've come to
realize that the statement you know
diets don't work can be really
discouraging for a lot of people and it
may also come off as a little
insensitive especially without giving
enough context around that statement
here's the thing most of the research to
date that we do have shows that for most
people
intentional weight loss diets do not
result in long-term weight loss in
contrast the evidence that we have on a
lot of these kind of like fad diets that
do show some kind of success are largely
very short-lived like I'm talking a lot
of these studies are like the length of
a typical one of Paltrow Cleanse and we
all know we're not doing that for long
having said that do I think it's
impossible to maintain a healthy weight
your whole life or to maybe get to a
weight that's higher than where you're
comfortable and to reduce it down to
where you feel your best
while some Hays advocates may suggest
that if you did it would come with a
punishing regime I think I've come
around to this grey area of possibility
and that's the possibility that yes you
can potentially lose some weight though
slowly and gradually just by making some
kind of small easy effortless changes to
your lifestyle and yes you can
potentially keep that weight off the key
I've learned is that these changes need
to be easy it needs to be pleasurable it
ultimately needs to be a journey that
comes down to getting in touch with what
our body really needs and letting go of
the shame that we feel around certain
foods this is really no different than
kind of what I've always said
however I am trying to position it in
the context of the possibility of losing
weight seeing as that is ultimately what
a lot of you have asked me about
specifically now finding and getting to
one's happy weight as I'll call
at happy weight does require potentially
a different level of hand-holding or
structure for different people depending
on their history and their relationship
with food for me you know I learned when
I was recovering from orthorexia that I
really had to reject all diet culture
and all diet mentality to be able to
trust myself to pick up on some of these
body sensations intuitive eating in its
full sense often works really well for
people who have kind of emotional
reactions to food either under eating or
overeating and that's why I knew
personally that I really had to kind of
go all-in in order for it to work for me
for others you know I can fully
appreciate that intuitive eating may
feel punishing in its permissiveness
that some people thrive on having more
structure and not having free rein may
cause more guilt and shame around food
choices some Hays practitioners might
say oh you know that's diet culture
talking and you just really haven't
healed fully yet and once upon a time I
would have absolutely said the same but
I've learned now that this isn't a sign
of weakness and ultimately we may all
just be programmed differently
not to mention well I think that we're
all at risk of falling victim to die
culture some people are just better able
to you know count calories or go on keto
or weigh themselves every single day
without having the same psychological
toll in the past just based on my own
past experiences I would have had a
really hard time appreciating that but
now I'm really trying to have an open
mind that both you know health at every
size or or intuitive eating and calorie
counting can both be tools in the same
dietitians toolbox for different clients
so should I pursue intuitive eating if I
want to lose weight well you know I did
not develop the intuitive eating
philosophy so I'm hesitant to come
across as like appropriating it however
I do think that the author's belief and
can
philosophy was that in order to fully
embrace the intuitive eating lifestyle
that one really should put intentional
weight loss and the pursuit of
intentional weight loss on the back
burner I personally think that's a wise
course of action however I don't think
it's right of me to assume that it's
impossible to incorporate and to learn
some of these important techniques while
still holding on to this pursuit in your
heart somewhere so if we think about
nutrition kind of like religion and this
amazing book by Evelyn Triple E and
Elise rush as like the Bible I think
it's reasonable to assume that we can
take from it what serves us and leave
behind what doesn't I think a lot of us
can agree that we do this with a variety
of religious scriptures so I don't see
why it's any different so yes Here I am
making a radical statement but I do
think it is possible to at least
incorporate some of these tenets into
the pursuit of reaching and maintaining
your healthiest happiest weight I want
to make it clear that I am NOT promoting
or promising any kind of weight loss at
all you know I've said it before that
unfortunately long-term weight loss is
can be really difficult for a lot of
people and it may come with unintended
risks like weight cycling and disordered
eating so it's really hard for me to
promise or promote a pursuit that has
potential risks like that but I'm just
saying that you have the right to pursue
weight loss if you yourself believe it
will help you and for whatever reason
that maybe you know it's really not my
business to judge I just hope that if
you do that you'll do so as
compassionately as possible so can you
fully embrace the intuitive eating
lifestyle and and find food freedom
while still pursuing intentional weight
loss again I didn't develop the model
but from what I know and what I've
learned I would say probably not fully
however that should not stop you from
trying to find a variation or a
comfortable way of eating that works for
you so how do you do that
well I think that listening to and
honoring your body's nutritional needs
is a given for anyone regardless of what
kind of nutrition or dietary lifestyle
you've chosen
but I think that incorporating
compassion and kindness and flexibility
into your eating regime is really the
key to preventing the shame and guilt
cycle that can easily turn intuitive
eating into the hunger fullness diet
which is ultimately destined to fail but
in order to have your cake and eat it
too your perception of what you're happy
weight is might need to change a little
bit you know it might not be the weight
that you were when you were 16 it also
might not be the weight that you've seen
a Fitness youtuber get to online but I
still really believe that we all have
like a set point range of our weight
where our bodies just thrive our health
just can thrive and I now can really
respect and appreciate people's desire
to do what they have to do to get there
so how do you lose weight without
slipping into the dangerous and
destructive hands of diet culture
honestly there's no way for me to tell
you for sure that you're safe for me it
is a slippery slope and it might be for
you as well but if you feel truly secure
in your relationship with food and you
feel that you know changing your diet
could ultimately improve your health
then I would say my tip for you is to do
it kindly slowly compassionately and in
a way that best supports your ultimate
well-being both physically and
emotionally
and most importantly shift the focus to
behaviors rather than the number on the
scale I've said it before
I mean maybe with a little bit less
compassion considering everything that
diet culture has taught us but
ultimately we don't have direct control
over our body or our weight there are
days or weeks like no joke when I feel
like I'm eating super healthy or
healthier than norm
and still for some reason out of the
blue my clothes don't fit well it's not
my fault it's just my body is doing
whatever it needs to do behaviors on the
other hand are things that I can
actually measure and actually change so
for me as an example a kind of easy or
compassionate behavior modification
might be to add like a serving of
veggies with my lunch or to make sure
that I have a really high protein
breakfast so that I don't leave the
house and then get ravenous mid-morning
and then eat like all the things later
on the other thing that I like to think
about is more about adding foods or
adding things to your diet rather than
thinking about taking them away so for
example if you're adding some lean
protein or healthy fats or fiber to your
dinner you're probably just gonna
naturally crowd out some of the late
night snacking or the treats without
feeling deprived as if you had said you
know I'm never eating cookies again
again I am NOT trying to tell you how to
lose weight I'm actually just kind of
giving you a bit of a sneak peek into
the gentle nutrition aspect of intuitive
eating and setting you up with some kind
of health minded tools to help you
achieve better nutrition status will you
lose weight no clue I don't know I don't
have control over that and ultimately
you don't really either but I'm hoping
that some of these little gentle
nutrition guidelines will just help to
improve your overall health but I just
want to say that if you've watched my
videos and you've thought to yourself or
you've said you know I just overeat
because something tastes good and I feel
better about everything when I'm on a
diet and pursuing intentional weight
loss this girl just does not get you I
do now I hear you and I am absolutely
here for you and I'm going to make sure
that there's a lot more content that
addresses some of your needs I hope you
will all continue to stick around and
learn with me it really means the world
so on that note if you liked this video
please be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with any
questions that you guys would have for
an upcoming video
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]